there is a family
and their home is invaded by four
strangers who have been asked to make a
choice of sacrifice to save Humanity why
are you here
I suppose I'm here to make friends with
you and your Dad's too
I believe in this type of Storytelling
that when you come to the movie theater
you want to see something incredibly
powerful incredibly emotional
experiential but you want it to be
bigger than life and feel something
bigger than life there is no place to
run there's no place to hide so I think
it's like layers of nightmares in this
film
foreign
I'm very drawn to stories of confinement
and telling very large stories through a
small window
that constriction that balance adjust
the position of the size of the story
and the way we're telling it is very
exciting to me families throughout
history have been chosen to make this
decision your family must choose to
willingly sacrifice one of the three of
you if you fail to choose
it just takes you on this journey of
your imagination you're just going to
the worst places but I think that's what
makes it terrifying I think it's just
that feeling of being unsafe
there's something quite seductive about
Apocalypse movies I've always found it
kind of combines two of my biggest
nightmares uh home invasion and the
apocalypse I suppose what really struck
me was that it was brave enough to go on
a kind of deeply spiritual journey even
though it's in a very interesting and
kind of shocking way and that's the the
goal and try to Aspire too that we make
a movie that feels singular
[Music]
foreign